hello everyone and a warm welcome in
joining us for the president's design
award 2020 recipients forum part two
creating a better world by design the
transformative power of design
my name is audrey lim your mc for today
the president's design award or pda for
short is singapore's highest accolades
for designers and designs across all
disciplines
organized by design singapore council
and the urban redevelopment authority
this is the 13th cycle of the award
on 30th june 11 recipients were
presented with their awards during the
pda 2020 awards ceremony
in the second of this two-part series
today's recipients forum features five
of the president's design award 2020
recipients
they will share how their design has
sparked economic cultural and community
transformation
hear how two of the projects have
elevated singapore on the world stage by
reimagining the future of construction
and civic spaces and learn how the power
of visual communication was harnessed to
drive home the message of the culture of
convenience educate youth on complex
topics such as fake news and climate
change and nurture singapore's design
scene
before we delve into the session proper
i'd like to highlight a couple of house
rules just to keep today's session
running as smoothly as possible
please be informed that this webinar
will be recorded and that your
microphones will be automatically set on
mute throughout the session
we will most definitely welcome
questions during the q a segment and you
may submit these questions through the
zoom q a function
should you encounter any technical
issues please reach out to our technical
team through the zoom chat function
last but not least this forum will be
accredited two cpd points for those of
you would like to apply for cpd points
to fill in the details required in the
survey form at the end of the forum
without further ado let's welcome
architect mark we executive director of
design singapore council to say a few
words
over to you mark thanks audrey um
well good evening everyone um speakers
ladies and gentlemen i think it's uh
fourth something so it's a
afternoon and evening welcome and thank
you for joining us virtually for
part two of the president's design award
2020 recipients forum part one on
designing for communities concluded last
wednesday
where six of our recipients actually
shared how they have designed for and
with the community and in doing so
created a better world by design today's
forum which our remaining five
recipients continues to illustrate the
transformative power of design
whether by reimagining the future of
construction and civic spaces nurturing
and preserving our design culture and
history
or by making difficult topics like
mental wellness climate change and
sustainability more relatable to
encourage positive calls to action
the president's design award is as
singapore's highest accolade for
designers and designs across all
disciplines and at the heart of the
award is its impact and value of design
as we celebrate the 13th cycle of the
award this year
more than ever especially against these
unprecedented times
are we reminded of our responsibility as
designers
and of design's higher purpose in
solving societal challenges to create a
better world i am proud to share that
these ethos are actually demonstrated by
the two designer of the year
and nine design of the year recipients
this year
and all of them are standard barriers
for singapore design
and all who have made a difference to
the lives of singaporeans and the global
community through excellent design
so through today's forum i hope that
each recipient sharing will be a unique
testimony of how design can be a tool to
empower lives
and uplift communities i hope also that
it will inspire and remind the designers
amongst us how innovative and empathetic
solutions are more important than ever
in a post-pandemic world
as we stand united and strive towards
becoming a more caring
and inclusive society
i'd like to wish everyone an engaging
and fruitful discussion ahead
and um before i hand the time back to
audrey i just want to thank all the
speakers for being here being super
awesome we would usually do this in the
auditorium
but um
well we have to do it this way and this
is the auditorium and this is the
national design center behind me
um but i'm looking forward and
have a wonderful evening
audrey thank you mark it is now my
pleasure to introduce the president's
design award 2020 recipients on our
panel today
designer of the year recipient ms kelly
chung
from the creative director of the press
room
design of the year recipient aya
represented by miss tanya wilson
co-founder and education lead of aya and
mr steve lola co-founder and head of
creative at aya
design of the year recipient the not so
convenient store represented by ms
astrid nursalim
creative director of kinetic singapore
design of the year recipient airmesh
pavilion represented by professor carlos
banyan director and co-founder of the
air lab at the singapore university of
technology and design
design of the year recipient jewel
changi airport represented by miss
charokutkaty
partner and director of softie
architects
let's welcome our first speaker miss
kelly chang to kick off the session
kelly is a modern-day polymath
ambassador and
who has been a tireless proponent of
design in singapore
over the past two decades she has
created a massive body of work spanning
visual communications exhibition design
and publishing
she is a passionate champion of design a
mentor for new talents and a generous
supporter and voice for fellow designers
architects and artists ms chang over to
you
thank you audrey
hi everyone i hope you are having a nice
afternoon
i would like to start my presentation
today by sharing a quote by instant
churchill
it says he said we shape our environment
thereafter they shape us
so
i think beauty is generally underrated
in singapore
because it actually has the power to
transform and define a nation
it is a kind of epigenetics that that
can actually be cultivated and it can
influence the character of a nation
take for example japan
they have a very strong design culture
and
if you go to japan before everything is
so uh they are so particular about
everything everything is so designed
even if you go and buy like a bento from
an uba sun
it is also very well designed for you uh
as opposed to let's just say in
singapore you go and buy your
mixed vegetable rice as the name itself
suggests you know it's
very messy
so um i think we have a long way to go
and uh hopefully as designers we can all
play our part and continue to push
boundaries to create duty um in our
society and that will actually help
in it's slow but slowly we can help to
transform
and also build um a better nation
through building
so uh
for me um i
always sorry let me click this
okay so uh last year during covet you
know
the newspaper reported that
art is uh the most uh you know
unimportant uh profession um
in in singapore during the profit which
is very sad because i think art and
design are absolutely essential to us as
a people
as we know you know as a society
progress and evolve
the art and design of a nation actually
show
um
show how your culture
and also how involved you are as a
people
so uh in our works uh we are always very
supportive of the of the arts community
because together design art we can
create you know a stronger culture for
our nation
um so we
have participated in many projects
with artists
collaboratively and sometimes as a
supporting role to bring out the value
of art to design
so these are some of the art projects
that we have done
another aspect that is
very important i think our role as
designers is um
to kind of find a purpose in
in the work that we do
um by giving back and contributing to
the society as and when we have the
opportunity
on the left uh is actually an annual
report we created for this non-profit
organization
called child's dreams it's actually a
swiss
non-profit company that provides
education and also
help facilities to under-develop
countries
to help them to help the children there
so we actually created the annual report
for them for free so as designers
sometimes i feel that we might not be
able to directly
effect some change
but we can always play a complimentary
role
so when we are able to give our service
to help non-profit organizations to do
the good work that they are doing which
is already
changing and transforming a society we
are also doing our part in
changing and effecting some positive
change for the society
so besides a child's dreams we have also
contributed to action for aids
tedx singapore which promotes
design
and education
and also social space is a magazine that
actually talks about the unmet needs of
the society
uh like the poor people the old people
you know um the physically challenged
people so and so forth uh game is a very
very meaningful magazine and we are
really happy to be able to play a part
to use design to
convey all these very important messages
to people a lot of times as graphic
designers
unlike architecture you know
architecture you can you can really
directly effect change through your
building because it's designed for
people to use but as graphic designers
uh
many times you know you can ask yourself
so so what is your role you know what is
your role and what's your purpose uh
in in the society
and i think a lot of times our role is
about conveying messages you know
communicating certain important
uh important messages
to to the general public and this is a
this is an invaluable uh invaluable
skill actually because sometimes
messages are very
difficult to talk about or or is is hard
to to
to be safe in a few words but as
designers we are able to sustainly uh
kind of capture that in a visual or in
as few words as possible and this
sometimes can be really life-changing
um the next point i want to talk about
about uh is about
how design can actually
help to promote a nation right so in
this case uh i think design can help to
advance the singapore brand singapore is
a relatively young nation so so a lot of
uh for you know in the 80s uh people
still think that singapore is a part of
china right but now we are doing so much
better so as designers whatever work
that we we push out to the world it
actually directly uh conveys to the
world and tell people who we are as one
people one nation and one singapore
national day right so uh so yeah so i
think it's uh what we do uh the if we
create really nice design for example
like whether it's architecture it's a
poster branding everything um it it
allows people to kind of piece together
in their mind what kind of a country or
nation that we are
so in uh
in quite a few uh of myself initiated in
my self-initiated projects
such as ish magazine uh it was started
in 1999.
during that time there was
internet was in its very early stages
and there was
no design magazines from singapore and
even asia
so um actually created this uh design
magazine the first design magazine in
singapore
to tell stories of designs and designers
in singapore and also
in asia
it uh it resonated with so many people
in not just the region in fact in the
end globally
that the the magazine became sort of
like a tool that brings the global
design community together
and uh of course subsequently i went on
to uh to run singapore architect
magazine for for eight years and there
again you know i i tried to push out as
much good works of architects
in singapore and uh that again kind of
resonated with quite a lot of people in
the world
we press room has been a long time
partner of tedx singapore which is uh
really very much about um promoting uh
innovators and thinkers in singapore so
uh we we recently just helped them to
make a book which uh
which
uh basically served that purpose i think
i'm disconnected from my clicker so
let me try again
okay
okay and um
some of the other self-initiated
projects that uh i have done is um it's
actually uh
15 minutes and night and day some of you
uh might have been there 15 minutes it
used to be a restaurant and a gallery
that is located in in lasalle
and night and day is actually a bar and
an art gallery in on salivi road both
spaces are created to kind of foster a
design our design community because i
always feel that interaction physical
interaction
is so important to build a design
community a community of any sorts in
this case i'm trying to provide this
space for conversations and interaction
for our local creative community from
artists performers designers etc so both
spaces uh provide
that kind of independent creative space
for anyone to come and perform their
offering so we have a stage in both uh
establishments and the art gallery
and they we featured a lot of local
artists giving them the
space to to voice their uh
uh
their concepts and their creative works
and all that um and the sometimes it is
about a design intent as well so i think
with that kind of design intent it it
actually did achieve the purpose of of
bringing the the design community
together and triggered uh many
different sort of collaborations and and
uh design activities uh from there so i
think physical space sometimes are um
really uh
underrated and and uh
uh they are important in
sort of uh making people come together
and do something
um
a part of my a big part of my career is
really about mentoring and nurturing
young designers because i always believe
that we need to
have an ecosystem you know a design a
healthy design ecosystem uh if we want
our design industry to go far you know
we need young blood we need we need the
old older designers to mentor the young
people so that they can outshine us you
know so every generation of designers
can be better and better and that will
make not only the design community
stronger and stronger it will also make
singapore
as a brand you know stronger and
stronger
the last point that i want to touch on
is about the importance of documentation
education that that would lead to
evolution
um for any uh society
you need to have a history
as a as a foundation for a culture to
evolve
and history is about documentation
so i think our design uh community our
design history is very underdocumented
and and in that sense a lot of the good
things
and the stories that our former design
designers have done uh uh you know uh
left undocumented and i find that
a real pity because some of these
amazing uh forefathers of our design
community have passed on or they become
very old and all that
and um
it uh it really pains me to see that
these people's uh not just their works
even their stories you know are not
documented
and i think documentation is important
because history is not just about good
things history is about good and bad
because we learn from the bad to become
better so it's not just about telling
good stories as well
um so i i really hope that i i can play
a part you know in helping to document
these uh stories and engines
and education i think uh in order for
for design to be better valued by our
clients to have better clients in the
future for our younger generation of
designers we need to educate the public
in general of what design means and how
it is a very specific skill and it can
be difficult so people need to respect
that and also to uh hopefully you know
then to pay us decently right
so i think uh having events and uh
having exhibitions and all that to
educate the public is also very
important and both this documentation
education will lead to an evolution of
our design community
so um i spent a lot of my time uh
helping to document a lot of design
history in in singapore
sometimes it's pro bono sometimes it's
sometimes you get a little bit of money
but for the most
uh times we don't get a lot of money but
i i like to see that
um each of us should play our part in
helping to build this
design industry in singapore so that we
can have uh eventually a culture can
evolve so these are some of the projects
that that i've done that is about
documentation rumor 50 documented 50
years of the architectural singapore
profession
our modern past is a very meaningful
project that uh i worked together with
uh two uh three writers dinesh uh
and talin and also uh the late jeremy
sun an amazing photographer so as a team
we came together and we documented all
the modernist buildings in singapore and
many of which have already been
demolished so
this this volume of three books is
really uh quite an amazing documentation
i hope that some of you have kept a copy
um on the right is um
i think the only full-time architectural
academic in singapore mr william lim he
has done many books and
[Music]
documenting theories and thoughts about
our urban city singapore is an urban
city and architecture in singapore
these are all very very important
thoughts and theories so we have also
helped him to document a lot of
this um
currently i'm working on this project
which will be launched in uh
with the
national design center uh supported by
vsg of course this website called
usml so i'm starting to do my part to
document the journeys and stories of as
many
designers
as possible so if i come to you please
please do your part and allow us to
document you because
as we started realizing it's not easy as
anything because there are some people
who say i don't want another one you
know it's gonna take up two hours of my
time to one to one
uh so we really hope that uh all of you
the design community community can give
us your support and if we come to you
please give us two hours of your time so
look out for
studiosml.net it is meant to be an
archival website that documents the
history of singapore designers they are
mostly they are journeys these are like
mini biographies uh that i think in time
to come 20 years down the road this will
be an invaluable archive for anyone to
tap into it's free and it can even
become educational materials for for
schools and all that who by then
hopefully should all be learning about
design
um this is a
an exhibition i did at uh national
design center in uh uh quite recently
two two zero one nine so i documented 20
years of my work and uh it really served
as an educational platform to also
educate people about
designs and uh
the thoughts behind design
so we we managed to to succeed quite a
good outreach um i think for a design
show we achieved 26 27 000 almost
visitorship
uh and our social media outreach
okay i'm overrunning okay so anyway uh
so we managed to have a really good
outreach
um and also uh in terms of in case in
instead of making a book we actually
made a website so it's kelly cheng.com
you can take a look this is also our way
of building towards a more sustainable
uh singapore because i think too many
books uh too much paper and all that so
we should we should digitize digitalize
uh our stories and knowledge so you can
you can read up more on kelly chang.com
about the exhibition at this point i
have to end because i'm already eating
into the time of other speakers so thank
you very much over to you audrey thank
you
thank you so much for that kelly for
your insightful sharing
next up we have miss tanya wilson
co-founder and education lead of ayah
and mr steve lola co-founder and head of
creative ayah aya is an educational
platform that uses visual communications
to nurture children's creative and
problem-solving skills the designers
have used design in a humorous yet
sophisticated way captivating and
educating children to understand more
about the world they live in and to be
part of the change they want to see miss
wilson and mr lola over to you
thanks audrey hello
um so hi everyone so we're going to talk
you through um a bit about aya so that's
exactly how we pronounce it it's uh the
singaporean colloquialism and that
element of surprise is really at the
heart of what we do
um aya is a not-for-profit that we
founded a few years ago and it really
combines our expertise of working in
visual communications with our passion
for education and nurturing the next
generation to be creative problem
solvers
so as as i'm sure you're all aware the
world economic forum cites critical
thinking creative thinking and complex
problem solving as key skills for the
future of work
and these are not necessarily skills
that are being developed
so much in primary and secondary school
so this is something that we want to
empower educators with materials that
they can they can help to nurture these
these creative muscles in students
so that eventually students become very
clear on what they can do that a
computer can't
do you mind going to the next slide for
me
it's not going to the next slide
hi sorry tech crew can you just help me
to is it crashed
well maybe while there's a break i'll
show you this is the physical format of
aya which is a
publication we create
um
mainly with illustrators to kind of uh
think about modern topics this is
obviously
um
quite potent
illustration uh and we work with artists
from around the world
um talking about things like uh
technology uh food wellness anyway funny
here you go it looks like we're up there
there we are there's me
there's there's steve's son there um so
we work with with artists and designers
from around the world to create
thought-provoking visuals that are used
as a trigger for discussion on complex
topics such as internet safety fake news
sustainability
mental wellness
we we provide these toolkits for
educators uh to use them in the
classroom and we've had some really good
feedback
um about some of the some of the impact
that i'm showing these visuals have so
in some lessons on internet safety
students at the end have come up to
teachers and said oh i think i've got a
problem with internet addiction so we
see that real um transformational power
of of creativity
we get them to practice their creativity
once we've got their attention with
these visuals we get them to practice it
for example caption contests so this
where there's no right or wrong answer
and you start practicing this this
creative muscle and maybe the students
who might not be great at maths in
english and science may really shine in
these kind of exercises and it's
creative writing which again is
something they don't necessarily
practice so much
um observation we get to find hidden
surprises this is an emoji land and this
links to a discussion about
emojis and non-verbal communication
who's the founder of the emoji one of
the most popular emojis
we use these these visuals that make you
look twice and use this
look-see describe analyze and interpret
methodology
where the need to understand the image
is is kind of intrinsic to human nature
and it invites curiosity and awareness
we we have interactive elements where
they might color in this very detailed
internet themed worksheet giving them
allowing them to spend time with an idea
and building confidence and enthusiasm
this is our fake news issue in a primary
school and we've asked the students to
combine any three images and create
their own fake news headlines and then
do a fake news quiz on carhoot and this
develops their creative abilities and
and again as a way to discuss fake news
in a fun way and capture their attention
finally self-assessment is really
important in in everything that we do
where they they have to reflect on their
use of devices how much time they spend
online and what they're doing online and
this
this develops self-awareness
um so
transformational creativity and we do
this on two levels by making difficult
uh subject matter approachable and
interesting and by constantly exposing
children to creativity and getting them
to practice their creative muscles and
our hope is that the next generation
will become smart problem solvers
here's some some visuals of of our work
in schools we got a school to do a
dangers of the internet collage
and you can see some of the results here
really quite impressive and we've made
also interactive versions of our of our
internet issue so that's a school
practicing that on the ipad
um
as earlier kelly talked about
exhibitions and pop-ups that's key to
what we do we do uh off to do
exhibitions we've just finished one at
the singapore maritime gallery we do uh
partnerships with fnb outlets to have
like healthy eating initiatives
that's a sushi sushi making workshop we
have our school kits youtube merchandise
and very active on social media
so
sort of one of our mottos is keep your
mind sharp and your eyes open
thank you
thank you for that miss tanya wilson and
mr steve lola our next speaker is miss
astri nurselim creative director of
kinetic singapore bringing you the not
so convenient store the nazi convenience
store is anything but a typical
convenience store instead it is italian
cheek reprimand that our culture of
convenience is killing the earth the
project is a strong vehicle for the
message of sustainability which comes
across efficiently without being preachy
ms nor salem over to you
okay hi everyone thank you audrey for
the introduction so the not so
convenient store come about when our
client tamasek shop house briefed us to
make an exhibition about waste and
sustainability
these are some of the challenges that we
face at the start so there are too many
people too many brands talking about
sustainability and we feel that the
public are already becoming tired to
hear about the same messages over and
over again so then the challenges for us
is how do we make it different and
create an impactful one
we could blame it on the ways the
disposable packaging and the plastic
bags itself but we thought why don't we
go to the roots of the problem so
surprise people is back to us
it's our culture of convenience why we
take away our food in disposable
containers instead of bringing our own
because it's more convenient why don't
we bring our toad back and instead we
take another plastic bag because it's
more convenient
so we decided to take the very iconic
symbol of convenience and turn it on its
head
so welcome to the note so convenient
store this is probably the first
convenience store to promote
inconvenience
so before i continue with my
presentation i'd like to show you guys
this video that summarized our project
convenience it's a big part of modern
life unfortunately so are its effects 2
billion tons of waste every year
mountains of plastic which take 1 000
years to break down more plastic than
fish in the seas by 2050 how can we get
people to move away from this culture of
convenience
introducing the not so convenience store
probably the first convenience store to
promote inconvenience
reusable straws you have to wash instead
of throw travel tumblers that add weight
to your bag capsules that take longer to
prep and clean
compost kits that require you to live
with wormy waste for months menstrual
cups that need to be emptied and cleaned
inconvenient zero-waste alternatives
like these line the shelves of the store
the drinks bridge is full of bottles and
cups that can be reused while the
freezer is repurposed as a recycling bin
every product comes with a tag that
spells out the price of convenience as
paid by the earth
this is reinforced by other displays
at the cashier notes on how to live more
sustainably are put in the till to
inspire change branding materials
continue in the same vein with playful
twists on customer service mottos
we enlisted sustainability champions and
influencers as employees of the month
serving as examples for others we also
created instagram stickers to help
spread the message on social media
turns out people loved being
inconvenienced the not so convenient
store was featured on the news and
multiple sites online
it also evolved into a mini movement
which saw people pledging their support
[Music]
you don't need to be a hero so bring
your waste down to zero find out more at
the not so convenience store
[Music]
okay yeah so from outside it looks
exactly like your everyday convenience
store but everything about it is set to
surprise the visitors the name the color
the design we have staff uh manning the
store that looks like a convenience
store stuff and also we create a special
jingle to create visitors you might keep
it at the end of the video just now
so this is how it looks like from the
inside you can see how everything is
displayed
to look exactly like a convenience store
uh here we have the products uh that is
your alternative to reduce your waste
we have like around 60 to 70 products
so we have like compost kit reusable
straws uh
menstrual cup
resource containers
then we have a fridge so instead of
displaying drinks we display reusable
bottles and our carbs
freezer instead of ice cream we purpose
it as an e-waste recycling bin and we
teach people on
how to
how to manage their e-waste
and instead of regular price tag we put
price of convenience versus price of the
not so convenient is to share with
people the bite size facts on waste and
sustainability
on the job display we have messages to
reinforce disability such as must not
buy because you may already have some of
the items at home and messages like buy
one get 1000 users for free to and
emphasis about the reusable messaging
on the cashier we put notes on how to
create chains
and then this is some of our posters for
the stall walls where we put a twist on
the customer service messaging like this
one here sorry for the inconvenience no
we are not because it's for the earth
here we have customers come first just
not here because earth comes first here
and then we have employees of the man
wall to share what the local security
players have been doing to set examples
for the visitors
we also have a tote bag donation corner
in the store
and this is so far what we have done we
have done three stores and we like that
the store can take on on many forms in
different places just like the user
convenience store and we think the
possibilities are endless
we also extend it to a social page by
creating a special instagram page for
the not so convenience store and by
doing this way we can share
sustainability messages little by size
facts about how to save the earth
we also extend it to instagram stickers
which are very very fun to play with
now we also have racks that feature
local businesses that have been
practicing sustainable choices and with
this way we hope that visitors can come
here and also get inspired uh see there
are
little ways that they can adapt to their
own businesses
but the store forms our eco local
community with these brands that
supports us
and we like it that by coming to the
store they can see all these many
products in once in one space instead of
going to many different places
and with no media budget we are very
grateful with the attention given from
the local and international
media it also gathers positive
sentiments from the public and creates
a positive chatters
so to summarize it shows that we design
we can transform a commonly used topic
into something fresh and surprises
people again and it loves and it allows
us to present solutions in small easy
steps to help solve a big problem
thank you
thank you miss ashley north salim our
next speaker is prof carlos bamion
director and co-founder of the air lab
at the singapore university of
technology and design
today he will share about airmesh
pavilion as one of the world's first
fully functional 3d printed space frame
structures
the pavilion is an emphatic proof of
concept that puts singapore firmly at
the forefront of global additive
manufacturing of complex structures and
is a model for a more sustainable future
welcome profpanyon
thanks audrey uh welcome everyone thanks
for uh attending
uh
well um in this five minutes i'm gonna
use them to talk about like the power of
the online design and particularly
related to 3d printing which is what i
mainly do
at the airlock so
but not just 3d printing just for the
sake of using technology because we want
to implement technologies with a
positive impact in sustainability
so an industry creates more than 20
million tons of construction waste every
year so it's sometimes underestimated
but it's definitely something we need to
do if we want to improve the way that we
build and we design and additive
manufacturing which is basically 3d
printing contributes to lower the levels
of energy in the production up to 21 so
actually
could be a technology that can change
the game um in the in the near future
but why we 3d paint in architecture
right that's the question that i'm also
trying to answer right so the few
reasons that i started my research in
first because mainly it is zero wastage
in fabrication right it's additive
manufacturing so you don't remove much
you don't want your fabricate which is
great
second is because it can create really
radical new aesthetics due to the full
freedom that we have with place
materials and third is that allows for
free form design in architecture
so we targeted the existing systems that
are standardized angles and geometric
discontinuity and we wanted to actually
create a free-form continuous system
looking at the way that we can build in
the future
so we combine our 3d printed node system
with standard components so we don't
disrupt the industry dramatically
basically we try to combine existing
products with our two printed notes
so we um we design our script that
creates all the components uh they're
all generated with a
digital design so we can print directly
from the files to 3d printer
and all components can
actually
be assembled into a very complex way in
a way that we can design these redundant
structures and this one for example the
one that we did in this tv in 2015 with
a radical reduction of material and also
um creating a gathering space for the
open house in 2015 that was the best
version of the system
then we
we wanted to explore because we are
printing uh with a lot of space inside
how we use the space to run services and
we start exploring using uh led lights
inside and running services inside the
structure so 3d printing allows to
create more efficient and even
a complete new aesthetics when we what
we designed so this was an art
installation that we did for the island
marina bay festival in 2017
when we use translucent nodes and bars
to create this kind of cloud-shaped
pavilion that was actually opened to
people to interact it was changing color
to touch to get close to the bar and the
quest was quite a experience for us to
push the system forward that was also
repurposed into a chandelier in the
national design center after the
exhibition was over
but also we're looking at renewable
materials like bamboo which is fast
growing and powerful carbon sink
so
we use technology and design to deal
with bamboo in a completely different
manner so we cut the bamboo poles we
scan in 2d with a super simple scanner
and then we send the information to our
script to print the components that can
actually extend the shape of the bamboo
in a seamless way so we created canopies
that can be assembled in less than a day
by a team of five
and this is aesthetics
we can create any shape
and this was induction hill for three
months we stand in really well and serve
a stage
for eventual concerts
four can we reduce the use of material
while maximizing a structural
performance then i looked stainless
steel as a material to print and to
experiment with
we went to the stream of working with
6mm
profiles extremely sense like a pencil
right so actually
printing the components in stainless
steel
we can create the connection between
those bars and achieving an outstanding
ratio between the load that we can take
about 200 kg standing only in three
small
supports this is the connection system
and the air table in 2018
[Music]
it was a seed for the air mesh pavilion
so can we design an entire space
producing zero waste between its
construction that was the question that
we formulated when we started the
airmesh pavilion so we scaled the size
of the nodes to this kind in which we
also uh designed the threads to connect
standard bolts to the bars those balls
are concealed inside the profile so you
cannot see the connection and the
connection is as fast as five seconds
with a hex key
it's like putting together your ikea
fully thread holes
at a larger scale
and the good thing is that this is a
high performance structure stainless
steel super safe
code compliant approved by bca so
almost disappears in the landscape
because it's extremely slender and thin
and then we cover it with a repurposed
fishing net
to create a breathable skin
and a space closer to nature framing the
views towards the
highlights of the gardens by the bay so
we achieved maximum structure
performance with minimal materials and
zero voices in construction and for us
this is just the beginning we are
exploring the system in vertical farming
and other vertical structures as well so
soon we will be sharing news about the
hermes 2.0 version
right thank you very much
thanks for that presentation prof carlos
benon last but not least our final pda
2020 recipient miss charokukate partner
and director of safety architects who
will share on dual changi airport
jewel changi airport redefines the
notion of an aviation transit hub by
creating a public-centric facility
accessible to transit passengers
not only does it represent a new
typology combining retail spaces
passenger conveniences and a garden
within a climate-controlled glass
enclosure it is also a powerful civic
landmark that places singapore firmly on
the world travelers map ms kakate over
to you
we might need you to unmute for us
really quickly
thank you
thank you audrey
um good afternoon everyone on behalf of
sabji architects i'm very proud to
present june change airport
that was awarded to our project to our
forum to an international design
competition
i am unable to
to change my slides
um
okay
this this is
the project is located in the center of
the channel at centre of chandi airport
and sandwiched between terminal 1 and
the control tower
as you can see it was a very very tight
side which
used to be an open-air car park with the
train running through it connecting
terminal 2 and terminal 3.
even though changi airport had a big
program which they gave us during the
competition which consisted of shopping
and
retail area as well as aviation
it was very challenging to design that
for a tight site but even it's in spite
of that
we strongly believe that in in addition
to fulfilling the brief our design
should include a timeless attraction a
community garden centered around a tall
waterfall
our design proposal consisted of 135 000
square meters of space spread over 10
floors that connected to all three
terminals
contrary to the traditional visual
design practice which always where the
shopping is in the center uh the focus
of our building is centered around a 15
000 square meter public garden
which is free of any commercial activity
and is accessible for 24 hours
this garden extends from level one to
the top level level five
and
as you can see uh sorry the slides are
really moving slow uh as you can see it
has it extends from level one to level
five where we've created multiple
attractions for families to enjoy
the waterfall center in the garden
creates an amazing serene space in the
heart of the airport the garden is
neither a decorative display nor
are not a simple botanical exhibit
within the building but a landscape of
grandeur and wonder
working with
amazing engineers and bureau apple
helped us rationalize the form of the
building the waterfall created a lot of
new challenges the toroid shape of the
building could not be symmetrical to
avoid the water falling on the train
bureau apple helped us create delicate
tiger shell structure to cover the
garden and the spaces below
we also worked with atelier 10 our
environmental engineers who helped us
with the designing of designing the
comfort of human beings and garden
because both humans and plants have
different needs we use different
strategies for selecting like by
selecting the glazing panels by using
radiant uh floor cooling to create
comfortable environment
the engineers also helped us to map the
natural daylight so our landscape
architects could select trees based on
the actual light that could come into
the building
for example at the highest level which
is very close to a roof structure uh we
selected trees with shade you know
canopy trees whereas as you go down we
should we selected trees that were tall
and light could filter down
we created full size mockups to test uh
to test and resolve some of our
construction issues in advance of the
main construction
the mock-ups helped the markups helped
us understand the landscape elements
paving design the facade structure and
even the behavior of the water how it
would fall from the stall height of 30
meters
but the biggest challenge was not so
much about these mock-ups but more of
the site the site was so tight it was a
logistical nightmare for the contractor
they were tasked to work with very
limited access to the site for the
trucks and equipment there are firm
deadlines for completion because it
impacted the neighboring terminals
this area which shows you how tight the
side is between the control tower and
terminal one
and because of the tightness of the side
construction workers different teams
have to work together all under
tremendous pressure working together to
complete their jobs in hand
and
sorry the slides are taking time
uh
this is a technical marvel in terms of
technology and in terms of the way the
structure is constructed
from digital engineering to automated
fabrication from precision manufacturing
to onset assembly this structure
represents radical advancement in
emerging technologies
in joule the garden is built entirely
entirely on the structure
the picture on the right shows you the
completed structure
and it took a lot of huge collaboration
actually between engineers and
architects and landscape architects and
environmental engineers structural
engineers all of them working towards a
common goal
a goal of creating something wonderful
and this is the result that we created
this is the result of the collaboration
effort
because after all a great building is
about relationship at the end
the building is very well connected
the building is very well connected to
all the terminals making it convenient
for the locals and travelers to access
it is also a first place where many
visitors come in and this is their and
appreciate singapore this is the new
gateway to singapore
it is also a new building paradigm where
range of facilities from aviation
to shopping and retail and entertainment
co-exist
they co-exist under one roof
in a comfortably air-conditioned space
jewel introduces people to wonders of
nature and plant lives
it it houses approximately 3 500 trees
and more than 100 000 shrubs from all
over the world
bringing natural light through the 14
meter high acrylic funnel extends the
wonder of the basement areas which
otherwise tend to be dull
it has become a precedent where nature
and city are one
a traveler can feel rejuvenated
and and a local residents are enthralled
but by what the place has to offer the
form of entertainment for families
and for families and kids all around
jewel is a building that belongs to
everyone locals and travelers
to see the citizens on wheelchairs who
sit and speak in peace and enjoy nature
in a comfortable environment
walking in the forest valley with the
forest around you sun pouring from the
sky rain in the form of waterfall
falling from the sky is like
experiencing a natural wonder and not an
interior garden
the same space transforms into a magical
wonderland in the evening
changi airport returns wonder to air
travel it lifts our beings and creates a
new paradigm of how we think about a
journey and the public spaces are
related to it
it does this by merging architecture
urbanism public space
landscape greenly and retail
in a new way
it's a complex hybrid layering of spaces
and experiences which brings people
together from all around the world it is
truly a place where singapore meets the
world and one meets singapore
new york times wrote an article about
vacationing at singapore's changi
airport
it's unheard of vacationing at an
airport which is such a stressful place
i must say
that after being involved in the project
right from conception till the end
this is a testament of teamwork and a
team's vision of designing and
constructing a place that can sustain
life
thank you very much
thank you ms kakati and thank you to all
our recipients for sharing on your
inspiring and impactful projects i'll
now hand the time back over to our
moderator architect mark we once again
for the q a session welcome once again
mark and the recipients
yeah hi everyone uh thanks for sharing i
i know we've i'm taking a little bit
more time so
what i want to do is maybe ask each of
you all a question
and then perhaps you know uh y'all can
answer that and then we can give some
time to the floor
to also answer some of the questions so
i think to everyone who's listening in
and you could still please type in your
questions that'd be great and i'll just
kick him off with sam first right um
kelly
um
to try to answer some personal questions
for his good
i wanted to ask you has that been a
specific moment or example that really
spoke to you
about
or impacted you by design's
transformative power i mean i just want
to hear what what
yeah
share share share stories about that
if you could
uh i i'm going to
share a personal story so when i was 18
years old i designed this album cover
called
the teenage hate it is uh it is by an
indie band called
phillis
this was done in 1990 1990
when the indie music scene in singapore
is still uh not not really happening you
know uh so
this this became the the best selling
indie album at that time at 5 000 copies
which is unheard of
so this album cover is i think it's
transformative
in in many on many levels what one is
for myself as an 18 years old
uh i was i was so happy you know because
i couldn't believe that album cover that
i
designed um
could you know sell so well and the
second thing is that at that point of
time up till 1990 you know as i
mentioned the indie music
scene in singapore is still uh not
really happening but this album kind of
opened the doors to many more
indie bands to to be launched and to to
you know uh make their own cut their own
album because they all have the
self-finance and all that and not many
uh not many independents there to do it
because they most of them sell 500
copies which you cannot even cover the
cost of recording and cutting the album
and all that so this um this album to me
is so meaningful because it opened the
door for indie music in singapore and
finally you know just about a month ago
this uh
company production company just got in
touch with me
they are making a documentary on the
singapore music scene and they said that
this is one of the most iconic album
cover
ever made in singapore so uh so yeah so
i mean it's a little story and uh and
and i really uh i mean i think it's a
good story and actually if you read
carefully the album cover patrick chung
the lead singer he wrote he autographed
the cover he said that thank you kelly
for designing this cover for free while
i make lots of money
hey
thanks for sharing that i think what's
more scary is actually i know about the
odd fellows right so that just gives me
a date as to how young i am ah i can't
reveal your age
to the eye to the ayah team hey i love
the name um b
i mean you mentioned we all were just
sharing earlier about how was really set
up where to teach teach people or teach
kids about things that computers can do
and also with just the idea of just more
and more user generated content
just coming out online and people
wanting and aspiring to be
youtube influencers and and
internet influencers key share a story
of impact your project has made
i mean sorry i guess what i wanted to
know which were the topics that
resonated best with the kids and to what
extent their designs actually helped to
create the impact and response i'm super
curious
and it's super refreshing to hear what
you're doing
uh okay well i mean you know some kids
prefer different themes obviously the
internet's hot topic because they all
love
internet and youtube and uh you know
like you say their their influences a
sort of like
um a big feature in their lives um so
there was several images
uh in the image in the internet issue
which are you know they provoked ideas
like uh being in a iphone prison for
example
um
you know trying to discuss perhaps this
idea of uh
isolation through through the phone
and sorry i should just hold it a bit
longer um you know and i think this
this idea didn't really occur to them
but when you quiz them on it they
realize that when they are
um
when they're on the phone they're not
interacting with their environment but
they actually also felt by the same
token they were interacting with
a different set of people you know their
virtual friends or or things like that
um
it's very hard to see but this is a sort
of um
it's a it's a landscape and what there
is there's cookies hiding
in the
in the landscape and
um we use this as a device so they had
to find all the cookies and then
it sort of prompts the discussion what
is a cookie you know um it's something
that's spying on you it's something
that's listening to you and of course
they didn't know about this so now um
they're aware of cookies uh good and bad
ones um
and i think one of the uh
one of the
sort of post um
workshop sort of uh feedback or results
that we did we did a survey of of uh
some of the information and what was
really interesting was uh
after the workshop i think it was 80
percent of the kids removed friends from
their friends list who they didn't know
in real life
and
um they didn't know that if they post a
photograph online it's online forever
they can't take it back down so these
are real uh basic things that they need
to know and they didn't know and
actually just by having that discussion
in a sort of warm environment
um
really
really had an impact a very visible
immediate impact so i think uh yeah
that's that's probably a good case study
well tanya you want to add anything to
that
you have kids how would they how they
check to your ayah oh they i mean they
love it they're always looking at my
computer and seeing what we're doing i
think they because my work sometimes
feels like play and i think it does to
them as well uh so the image behind me
that that's
one of the images we had for our trash
issue and it's a scene of chaos and the
arctic and they've got to find the
penguins and teachers are saying to us
you know sustainability and climate
change can be a bit
doom and gloom but we do it in a very
fun and colorful way and and um that's a
different way of approaching it which
which the educators appreciate and the
kids they they love that kind of where's
wally colorful illustration and they
love finding things in it i think
they're naturally observant and curious
and this brings out those traits and
celebrates them
well
yeah i i think you all might be able to
find all the future creative art
directors in singapore
by the ages of like 10
so maybe
thanks for sharing about that um i don't
know i mean to to as3 i just wanna i've
been to the non-convenience store we had
one at the national design center um
it really touched me but i i wanted to
understand i saw a lot of young people
going through it can you share us
perhaps a story of impact that your
project has actually made on people i
mean i know so many have been through it
but any personal stories that you
actually were able to encounter about
the impact of the store
yeah yeah so i guess the
interesting thing about our stores is
it's full of small actions that people
can take so i see it in different uh
it's adapted
i see it in a lot of people around me
like especially like my husband he used
to be an ignorant man he just take
another disposable cups every other day
but now he brings his own cups he
he wash his own plastic containers and
then you we we use it again at home then
i also see it in the people in the
office so it also the project itself
makes us also reflects on
on our habits so now in our office when
we go out to taobao the drinks we bring
the cups from our office and then when
we go on shoot instead of taking another
plastic bottles all of us bring our own
drinking bottles outside
wow
thanks you say he was an ignorant man i
mean that's the one i'm going to
remember
[Laughter]
thanks a lot no i i think it's really
been kind of amazing that kind of
impacts it's made um
carlos i i i didn't manage to i think i
saw the pavilion and when i was walking
by i didn't know what i could get into
it
right but i mean to be honest uh
as an architect it's it's just
mind-boggling because technically you've
kind of created a language or technology
to build anything
what other uses can you know your mesh
design and technology be applied to
any future plans to extend its impact on
other social or community areas of need
yeah i mean i'm happy that uh i mean i
give some people to say i i haven't seen
your pavilion i have i've been in the
gardens i haven't seen it i like that
it's not in a mainstream location it's
kind of
hidden somewhere and even if you're
close it's quite you know invisible
because it almost disappears so i'm
quite happy about that
and regarding the system yeah i mean
we're working to to scale the system
right so uh before the hermes is not
just
one pavilion it's a system so it's it's
a it's a proof of concept that it works
and the idea is to density in different
conditions right it's an adaptable
system and we have tested it in
different materials we have used the
bamboo ones for low cost construction we
are using the telescope for more high
performance
construction
so so we are targeting developing
actually now the some disaster relief
structures that can be assembled in just
a few hours by untrained people so
that's one of the breaks we're working
right now
and uh and the clouding doesn't need to
be a mesh i mean the planning could be
glass could be a sort of channel to be
something uh adapted to our system so
it's quite flexible in that way
and uh we also got uh inquired to design
a house like station of a shop house or
we're gonna test the
the system in uh in a real life
condition
and um but also we are we're pushing the
system also to build more adapted
and efficient shelters for our sport
bases and community centers in singapore
and uh and by end of the year we're
testing it as well in vertical farm
building so the idea to create the
necessary conditions for the plants to
grow and optimally and with an added
value of aesthetics and
the personalities so we are expecting to
have something to show by end of the
year
wow
heck that's a lot
you should make that
the could be an inconvenient house
yeah we should and it could be a site it
could be a classroom for aya actually
thank you i mean i think everyone's been
into jewel
how can they not
as an actor i know these projects would
have taken years of your life
but what do you think
is the intangible impact joel has had on
singaporeans or tourists such as people
and maybe you could speak to that
uh in light of how travel has actually
also changed dramatically with the
pandemic i mean i'm sure you know these
things
uh uh issues you get our answer to that
yeah uh let me start with the intangible
thing you know when you look at a
building or something very nice people
go there and people say wow
and they see it once and they see it
twice they see it rising that's it it's
like a wow factor and that wow factor it
has a short life because something else
better comes in
the thing with jewel is because it it
involves nature and natural light
and then because of the natural light
the way the whole atmosphere keeps on
changing i think it has created a sense
of wonder
what we found it remarkable was when
people come in and there's a sense of
wonder in their eyes they look at it
they're like wow look at this garden
where did it come from you know these
trees
where does the water come from where
does the water go when they go down to
the basement to see where the water goes
they're shocked to see that they can't
hear the waterfall
because of the acrylic cover and that
was something surprising even to us
because the acoustical engineer said it
would make so much noise it would be
like trucks on a highway
you know and
what happened was there was absolutely
quiet silence when you go to the
basement and i think this itself you
know for me even after working on this
project for so many years
i'm amazed by the quality of light you
get and how the light changes
it's it's it's fun to see
a rainbow in the morning near the
waterfall
it's fun to see how the light changes
filters down and how you can see uh the
diagram the shadow of the diver in the
water it's fun to see how it changes in
the evening
and then the and then the projections on
the water itself is very interesting
that what people like so you know it's
it's that's what keeps on changing
that's that's a very uh
that's something that you don't think so
much about design about you know you
don't think you don't think you're going
to create a sense of wonder that's not
something that you create it just
happens you know when everything comes
together the right way it just happens
um
during covert it was even more
interesting because there were a lot of
people who could not go out because it
was raining it was hot all sorts of
things people were going into jewel so
before kovac there were travelers
transition travelers who would stay an
extra day in singapore just to visit you
we met so many of them they would write
to us we remember so many people who
said okay you know what i'm traveling
from australia i'm going to london but
i'm going to take a day's
half and i'm going to just stay in june
or i'm going to spend a day in jewel
kind of thing
and now because the airport is closed
can you imagine without jewel there
would be no one going to charlie airport
but today with jewel people are still
going to change
and because of that the terminals are
still open the fnb is still kind of open
for you know for people to get there
i've seen older folks and you know
people on wheelchairs sitting and
enjoying which which they find it
difficult to do out outside and i think
i think that's sort of uh when we say
that this building is for one and all we
really mean it it's it's not just for
people who like shopping it's not just
for people who like to eat it's not just
people who like to just you know
see nature it's all together
and
most importantly it exists in an airport
which is sort of unheard of you know
airports are really stressful places
to have a garden a huge garden and
shopping in the airport in such a manner
i think um that has really made a
difference
you for planning
yeah
well i mean it's really first impression
is like the book the air-conditioned
nation it's like singapore and a bubble
right
i have one there's some questions out
here i want to kind of put out one maybe
for kinetic theorists and it's a
question around curious to know if there
were any other concepts considered
besides a convenience store and how do
you land on that idea
i'm sure everyone
has asked you that before
okay so when we first have the
the brief and then we get to the inside
it's actually it went pretty
straightforward for us
when we thought about the insect
convenience and then we linked it to the
convenience store
so we kind of don't have the discussion
about like what other icons to link into
convenience store
yeah
we kind of all agree to that to that
iconic symbol of convenience
i see
okay
this is a good idea
i think it's because like convenience
store have a very strong design elements
that we all designers kind of can relate
to and also there are a lot of design
elements that we can play with so i
guess when the idea comes out we all
just kind of go
go on well with the possibilities on
extending the design yeah
okay
well thanks for sharing that um
okay well okay we got a couple of
minutes and there's a bunch of questions
right i think you all can read
i'm either thinking of the last okay
maybe we ended last time as they all see
there's one around how can designers
stay relevant and contribute
meaningfully to solve challenges uh and
society especially in these
unprecedented times we're living in i
think all of you all have
amazing skill sets as you in your own
realms
how what kind of role do you think y'all
can play
or designers should play in this crazy
world going forward maybe this is
something for everyone
who wants answer first
okay i'm just gonna throw it at carlos
[Laughter]
by myself i mean um i think seven years
ago
um i think i was um
a completely different designer so i
think it's definitely
um
the times in which we are going to keep
ourselves as designers
as fluid as possible as open to learn
offer to transform
and and to find ways uh to create impact
by design and probably also to look at
technology as a way to to magnify or our
power as designers right so i think um i
found myself like the last seven years i
i i evolved a lot uh and i i and i i'm
practicing in a completely different way
than i did before so i think it's a it's
a special moment in which designer maybe
we need to actually be even more open to
transformation um so i think it's uh
just keeping ourselves really open to
update and go even deeper in the thing
to do wow
charu
women who created a sense of wonder
i think i think that by creating spaces
uh that bring in more of natural
environment
spaces that inspire i think that's an
important thing to do i think having
offices that are just totally with
artificial light and everything i think
that's that's really taking a toll on
people people are working long hours and
they need to have something that is more
nurturing
and uh and i think uh kovit has shown
that when people stop going out nature
survived i think it's the same thing
with people i think that we need to
bring nature and people together i think
greenery is not just the greenery on the
roads and streets and beautiful trees i
think it needs to be incorporated more
in natural light and green needs to be
incorporated more into everyday living
that is more people are spending time in
the offices so i think that needs to
happen i think it's important to
uh nurture people you know and
by creating environments that help
so true thanks for the answer stephen
tanya i mean
i mean the crazy world out there i mean
i'll add things like fake news and
things like that it's just even things
that y'all battle with in your realm
around communication
what's your answer to that question
around what kind of role designers can
play or your company
i think like being critical you know i
mean
uh
in a constructive way so whether you're
a designer or whether a consumer or
whatever
if you're kind of constantly questioning
how to improve things how to
uh how can this be better
um
they seem to be the obvious uh
response to things like
environmental improvement
uh processes which are wasteful
uh things like that so yeah it's pretty
generic advice but it's also quite key
to
designers who are constantly sort of
questioning
the reason for most things and can they
be improved upon i think that that's
part of our dna and it should be also
the way that the the main public thinks
wow great
and yeah
um i mean for us we we look at um
some of the needs that we're seeing in
education with children mental wellness
is something that when we're focusing on
at the moment how can we empower
educators and parents and social workers
to talk to young people about their
mental wellbeing and we've heard that
that some some adults feel um it's quite
stigmatized to talk about that topic and
we believe that visual communication can
completely remove that stigma
uh and so that's what we're focusing on
now we see there's a need for that
specifically at the moment so that's an
urgent need
wow so good man history
yeah
i think for us as i think we think as a
designer that we have to be more in tune
in this time in this pandemic because a
lot of people are having a difficult
time so i think when we are more in tune
we listen and see what are the problems
around us and only by then we can uh
know the real insights on what's
happening around us and therefore
creating a solution through designs
yeah
you're a storyteller and kelly how may i
mean you end with your answer
so uh yeah so i think as communication
designers graphic designers
a lot of times
it is about conveying the right messages
uh so for example i mean for us
we created the first vaccination
campaign in singapore in january to get
people to go and get jet so with the
poster not nice nobody wants to get jet
you know so very important
so yeah so i think uh uh as as graphic
designers uh as mark you just said we
are story tellers uh we are we need to
communicate
the right messages and to get people to
do the right things a lot of times so
like for example sometimes i message
very simple happy family you know you
get jet and everybody stays healthy
um so i think that's the power of design
to make it as simple as possible for for
anyone because this uh this campaign is
for old people young people and all that
and uh and yeah that's uh that's really
the power of design
wow thanks
for all the credit i know there's some
questions out there that we can't answer
but we'll reply directly but thank you
uh thank you for all the all your
speakers
uh
the future is crazy but i think just use
it we should continue to be critical and
question and also
really kind of use our skills to just
provide hope and let's do it together
over to you audrey
thank you so much once again mark and
recipients for sharing all your
experiences with our audience to our
guests we'd also appreciate it if you
could complete a short survey for this
webinar to help us improve on our future
programs please scan the qr code for the
survey form
for those of you who would like to apply
for cpd points please also scan the same
qr code you see on the left of the
screen and submit your particulars by
today if you would like to find out more
about the various upcoming programs the
national design center has lined up to
also scan the qr code you see on the
screen and if you'd like to find out
more about the recipients please visit
our website pda.designsingapore.org
and with that we will be ending the
session for today thank you once again
to all our speakers and to all of you
thanks once again for spending your
thursday afternoon with us my name is
audrey have a great evening ahead
goodbye